so what do you want to do tonight like I
was thinking maybe we can meet up with
Amy and Brad and late before that we
could go to Angelo's and before that we
could like just go I have something to
say I had to say in person because it's
it's like super important okay I know
this is sudden like I've been thinking
about this for a while and I know this
is something that needs to happen I'm
breaking up with you
cool love it totally find that bad
really
yeah cuz I thought I was really worried
that you're gonna be like mad mad oh my
god are you kidding me no of course I'm
not mad people grow apart it happens
it's like part of life no I'm totally
fine like love it love it love it you
know we had a good run
don't be stranger yeah can I just can I
ask why why yeah like what I was like
I'm doing some work on myself and like
trying to grow as a person so really
like appreciate to know why yeah um okay
yeah that's like you know I think that
you're kind of like a controlling person
thank you thank you for that that's nice
thank you for attendance cool no problem
so you know your problem is Andre what
you keep tabs on people every little
thing somebody does you have to keep a
tab of it wait I I can't tell if you're
angry or not I'm not I'm totally not
angry oh no I'm excited it's good it's
just like you said your piece and I just
think that I deserve the human decency
to say my piece right right is that that
not okay yeah no no of course of course
you're a controlling manipulative person
everyone says that I don't think that I
am yes you are Andre yes
[Music]
okay not now you like you sound pretty
angry I'm not angry I'm fine I love it
I'd love that you came to my house and
you broke up with me in my space and I'm
gonna think about that every time we
hear that's great that is still perfect
for me supposed to do it is you won't
come to my house we're carrying I wanted
to puppet master is back but I'm not I'm
looking about the population doing this
to me it's true you won't come to my
house at my apartment looks like two
rats just in it every day
I'm sorry okay me I guess I didn't think
it through
it's like too late now I mean we're
dying no it's not too late
Meegan Meegan seriously I just I was I
had a feeling that I thought was true
and clearly clearly it wasn't true not
breaking up with you because so when you
want to cheat inmate like I wanna hang
out with Amy and Brad but maybe before
that was good again smug
what you snap
[Music]